tj
good afternoon
thanks everybody for giving me the
opportunity to be here i'd like to make
a few comments
on the situation in russia and ukraine
and then i'd be happy to take your
questions
we continue to to see signs of russian
escalation including new forces arriving
at the ukrainian border
as we've said before
we are in the window when an invasion
could begin at any time should vladimir
putin decide to order it
i will not comment on the details of our
intelligence information but i do want
to be clear it could begin during the
olympics
despite a lot of speculation
that it would only happen after the
olympics
as we've said before
we are ready either way
we are ready to continue
results-oriented diplomacy that
addresses the security concerns of the
united states russia and europe
consistent with our values and with the
principle of reciprocity
we've continued to make that clear to
russia in close coordination with our
european allies and partners
we are also ready to respond decisively
alongside those allies and partners
should russia choose to take military
action our response would include severe
economic sanctions with similar packages
imposed by the european union the united
kingdom canada and other countries it
would also include changes to nato and
american force posture along the eastern
flank of nato and it would include
continued support to ukraine
the president held a secure video conf
conference today with key allies and
partners to coordinate our approach to
this crisis the participants were the uk
france germany italy canada poland
romania the secretary general of nato
and the presidents of the european union
we have
achieved a remarkable level of unity and
common purpose
from the broad strategy down to the
technical details
if russia proceeds
its long-term power and influence will
be diminished not enhanced by an
invasion
it will face a more determined
transatlantic community
it will have to make more concessions to
china
it will face massive pressure on its
economy and export controls that will
erode its defense industrial base and it
will face a wave of condemnation from
around the world
if on the other hand russia truly seeks
a diplomatic outcome it should not only
say so it should pursue that diplomatic
outcome we are prepared to do that we
have put concrete proposals on the table
they are now out there for the world to
see we're prepared to engage on them and
to discuss the principles and parameters
of european security with our european
partners and with russia
whatever happens next
the west is more united than it's been
in years
nato has been strengthened the alliance
is more cohesive more purposeful more
dynamic than at any time in recent
memory
in terms of immediate next steps
president biden and his team will remain
in close contact with our allies and
partners to coordinate both on the
potential for diplomacy and on any
response that is necessary should putin
decide to order military action
we are continuing to reduce the size of
our embassy footprint in kiev
and i now want to take a moment to echo
what both president biden and secretary
blinken have already said
we encourage all american citizens who
remain in ukraine to depart immediately
we want to be crystal clear on this
point
any american in ukraine should leave as
soon as possible and in any event in the
next 24 to 48 hours we obviously cannot
predict the future
we don't know exactly what is going to
happen
but the risk is now high enough and the
threat is now immediate enough
that this is what prudence demands
if you stay
you are assuming
risk
with no guarantee that there will be any
other opportunity to leave
and there no prospect of a u.s military
evacuation in the event of a russian
invasion
if a russian attack on ukraine proceeds
it is likely to begin with aerial
bombing and missile attacks that could
obviously kill civilians without regard
to their nationality
a subsequent ground invasion would
involve the onslaught of a massive force
with virtually no notice communications
to arrange a departure could be severed
and commercial transit halted
no one would be able to count on air or
rail or road departures once military
action
got underway now again i'm not standing
here and saying what is going to happen
or not happen i'm only standing here to
say that the risk is now high enough and
the threat is immediate enough that
prudence demands that it is the time to
leave now while commercial options
and commercial rail and air service
exist while the roads are open
the president will not be putting the
lives of our men and women in uniform at
risk by sending them into a war zone to
rescue people who could have left now
but chose not to so we are asking people
to make the responsible choice with that
i'm happy to take your questions yeah
i know you don't want to get into the
intelligence but can you give us any
sense what has changed over the past 24
or 48 hours to lead to your new level of
concern well first i would say when i uh
appeared on the sunday shows last
weekend i made the point that we were in
the window that russian military action
could begin any day now and that remains
true it could begin any day now and it
could occur
before the olympics have ended i'm not
going to get into intelligence
information but if you look at the
disposition of forces in both belarus
and in russia on the other side of the
ukrainian border from the north from the
east
the russians are in a position to be
able to mount a major military action in
ukraine any day now and for that reason
we believe that it is
important for us to communicate to our
allies and partners to the ukrainians
and to the american citizens who are
still there i want to be crystal clear
though we are not saying that a decision
has been taken a final decision has been
taken by president putin what we are
saying is that we have a sufficient
level of concern based on what we are
seeing on the ground and what our
intelligence analysts have picked up uh
that we are sending this clear message
and it remains a message that we have
now been sending for some time and it is
yes it is an urgent message because we
are in an urgent situation to clarify so
you now believe that russia has all the
forces it needs to mount a full-scale
invasion of ukraine what i'm saying is
that russia has all the forces it needs
to conduct a major military action i'm
not sure exactly what you mean by quote
full-scale invasion but russia could
choose in very short order to commence a
major military action against ukraine
yes nato told the president that it will
call up the nato response force of
americans who have been put on that
short leash and is the president
prepared to send additional unilateral
forces to our partners in
the border region of ukraine and is it
your judgment and the judgment of u.s
intelligence and the u.s government that
putin is behaving as a rational actor in
his judgments at this point
so on the question of the president
authorizing more unilateral us forces to
europe he's been clear all along that he
is open to doing so as circumstances
warrant but i want to be very clear
about something these deployments of u.s
service members to poland romania to
germany
these are not
uh soldiers who are being sent to go
fight russia in ukraine they are not
going to war in ukraine they are not
going to war with russia they are going
to defend
nato territory
consistent with our article 5 obligation
they are defensive deployments they are
non-escalatory they are meant to
reinforce reassure and deter aggression
against
nato territory in terms of the u.s
forces that have been put on heightened
readiness to be deployed in the event of
a nato decision to deploy them the
president had the chance as part of the
discussion today to hear from the
secretary general no decisions have been
taken in that regard but those forces
stand by should a decision be taken by
the north atlantic council to call up
the nato
response force uh
and a request comes in for american
forces to be a part of that finally
i can't get inside the head of president
putin i'm not going to speculate as to
his motivations his intentions or at
this point his decisions all i will say
is that we are ready either way if
president putin wants to engage in
diplomacy we are prepared to engage in
diplomacy we would like to find a
diplomatic path forward and we've
sketched out the parameters and
principles for that if president putin
chooses to move forward we will work in
lockstep with our allies and partners to
respond decisively yes jake it sounds
like you're saying that the assessment
previously that putin has not yet made a
decision
still stands so i guess based on that is
it your assessment that it's more likely
that invasion could happen now than
previously believed
look it's hard to assign percentage
probabilities to any of this we
have to think about the range of
scenarios that we confront and it's our
job to be ready for all of them so what
i will say is that the way that he has
built up his forces and put them in
place
along with the other indicators that
that we have collected through
intelligence
makes it clear to us that there is a
very distinct possibility that russia
will choose to act militarily
and there is a reason to believe that
that could happen uh on a reasonably
swift time frame now we can't pinpoint
the day at this point
and we can't pinpoint the hour but what
we can say
is that there is a credible prospect
that a russian military action would
take place even before the end of the
olympics the morning that you just
delivered to americans who are in
ukraine saying that they should get out
now while they still can do you have a
picture of how many americans right now
are in ukraine
i would refer you to the state
department for the specifics on this
because
i don't want to do it off the top of my
head there's basically two categories
there are those who have registered with
the embassy and those who have not
registered with the embassy in the first
category obviously they have a number
although some of those folks have
already left and didn't deregister in
the second category uh we don't know
because of course no american is
obligated or required so you can't fix a
perfect number but they're the ones who
are best positioned to be able to
explain what our current picture is of
american citizens in ukraine what i can
do is stand before the world media and
send a very clear message to to all
americans and and to any american who's
in ukraine right now who needs help
needs financial help or needs logistical
help to take advantage of a commercial
option to get out please call the u.s
embassy in kyiv because
we stand ready to provide that help yes
um the two quick questions one um are
you looking at this being some kind of
attack on heave on the don boss on
another region do you have any sense of
that and then what is the
level of confidence that the
intelligence community has in what
they're hearing about this plan
especially about the potential for to
come before the interview
when you say
i'm sorry can you repeat the second
question just around the confidence that
the intelligence
world has around
whether um
[Music]
this will happen before these events the
intelligence community has sufficient
confidence that i can stand before you
today and say what i have said which is
that there is a distinct possibility
that vladimir putin would order
uh a military action and invasion of
ukraine uh
in this window in this time period and
that could include the time period
before february 20th before the beijing
olympics had been completed
and so uh they believe that that
everything i have just said is well
grounded in both what they are seeing on
the ground and and what they are picking
up through all of their various sources
now to your question about what type of
action it would be we've been clear that
it could take a range of different forms
but i want to be equally clear that one
of those forms
is a rapid assault on the city of kyiv
that is a possible
line of attack course of action that the
russian forces could choose to take
they could also choose
to move in other parts of ukraine as
well the last point that i would make
and i know this has been the subject of
a fair amount of back and forth between
the administration and the press over
the course of the past week we are
firmly convinced that the russians
should they decide to move forward with
an invasion or looking hard at the
creation of a pretext a false flag
operation something that they generate
and try to blame on the ukrainians as a
trigger for military action and we are
calling that out publicly because uh we
do believe that if russia chooses to do
that they should be held to account the
world should not believe uh that a false
flag operation that they conducted uh is
a legitimate cautious belief for going
into ukraine yes
you you mentioned that you do not want
to say uh that putin has made a decision
but can does the united states believe
that the president pardon me that
president putin has made a decision
because pbs newshour just reported a
little bit ago that the united states
does believe that putin has made a
decision and has also communicated that
decision uh to the russian military is
that accurate the report that you just
referenced which i have not seen yet it
does not accurately capture what the us
government's view is today
our view is that we do not believe he
has made any kind of final decision
um or we don't know that he has made any
final decision and we have not
communicated that to anybody yes follow
up on that it's my colleague nick
schifrin who's doing that reporting he's
citing three western and defense
officials who say the us does believe
that putin has made up his mind has
communicated that to the military and
that they've been shown intelligence on
that you're saying that's not true what
we have communicated to our allies and
partners all 30 allies in nato plus a
range of other partners
our latest intelligence information and
it does not include a statement that
vladimir putin has definitively given an
order to proceed with the invasion yes
from your nato allies either i'm sorry
you haven't been shown any evidence or
briefed on intelligence that speaks to
that from nato allies
we have not seen anything come to us
that says a final decision has been
taken the go order has been given what i
will say and the reason i'm up here
talking in the way i am to american
citizens the reason we are taking the
various actions we're taking the reason
the president convened uh our closest
allies and partners from across the nato
alliance in the european union is
because we believe he very well may give
the final go order that is a very
distinct possibility but we are not uh
standing here before you today and say
the order's been given the invasion is
on uh it it may well happen it may well
happen soon
but we are not saying i think the way
that you've just characterized that i
have not seen this pbs report yet but as
you've characterized it that does not
capture the communication that we
are making to our nato allies nor uh
what we understand internally yes
given the risk that you've laid out the
fact that you're not uh 100 certain that
putin has made a decision yet we have
seen other world leaders meeting with
putin has there been any more thought to
president biden engaging with him
directly i would expect that president
biden will uh engage by telephone with
president putin but i don't have
anything to announce for you on that
right now
because this is getting so close now and
the concern that you're you're weighing
towards the american people is there
need to provide some underlying evidence
of just what you're seeing that shows
americans this is a country that went
through iraq and and concerns about what
the intelligence is showing
does the administration see a need to
just provide underlying intelligence
well let me just start with a
fundamental distinction between the
situation in iraq and the situation
today
in the situation in iraq intelligence
was used and deployed from this very
podium to start a war
we are trying to stop a war to prevent a
war to en to avert a war and all we can
do is come here before you and give good
faith and share everything that we know
to the best of our ability while
protecting sources and methods so we
continue to get the access to
intelligence we need but there's another
big difference between what happened in
2003 and what's happening in 2022 and
that is in that case
it was information about intentions
about
hidden things stuff that couldn't be
seen today we are talking about
more than 100 000 russian troops amassed
along the ukrainian border with every
capacity out there in the open for
people to see it's all over social media
it's all over your news sites so
you can believe your own eyes that the
russians have put in place the
capabilities to conduct a massive
military operation against ukraine
should they choose to do so and then
finally i would just say if you look at
the course of the past few months as we
have said we predict there will be a
buildup of this kind our information is
telling us that the russians are likely
to move in these ways
thus far in november in december and
january that has borne out so i think
when you take all of that together we
put forward a credible case but it's not
my job to stand up here and convince any
of you of anything it's it's your job to
ask the questions and do what you can do
all i can do is based on the best
information i have available that i can
share that the president can share the
secretary of state can share put that
out there
in close consultation with our allies
and partners that's what we've done yes
point jake would you expect the country
would hear directly from the president
on this and then the risk to world war
of vladimir putin rolling tanks or
bombing a foreign capital well first the
country has heard from the president
directly on the ukraine subject many
times over the course of the past three
months and they will continue to so
uh it's not like
president biden has been silent on this
question he has been very vocal on it he
has spoken to every aspect of it uh he
has read out his calls on it with world
leaders his meetings etc um but he will
continue to speak directly to the
american people as we watch uh the
situation unfolding for any kind of
address to the nation from the oval
office no kind of speech specifically
about this issue with prepared remarks i
i don't have anything to announce in
terms of uh
speech or prepared remarks at this point
so you and other administration
officials have been quite transparent in
describing the strategy towards ukraine
to us the press do you believe that that
strategy is actually helping uh to
reduce tensions or do you feel that that
may be part of the reason why it's
boxing vladimir putin even further uh in
in airing your strategy so publicly like
this
so uh only one country has amassed more
than a hundred thousand troops on the
border of another country with all of
the capabilities and capacities to
conduct an invasion that country is
russia that country is not the united
states so the fastest way to de-escalate
this situation for all involved would be
for russia to choose to de-escalate its
mobilization of forces the united states
is responding
to
the active sustained buildup of military
pressure on ukraine we are doing so in
lockstep with allies and partners and at
the same time we have been
extremely forward-leaning in our
willingness to engage in diplomacy to
address the mutual concerns of russia
the europeans in the united states when
it comes to european security
thank you so much
two questions for you next week vice
president is going to germany for the
munich security conference
why isn't president biden going uh
wouldn't it be a good time to engage
with his allies in person uh is he doing
enough to avoid a war and the second
question next week the brazilian
president is going to russia to meet
with the vladimir putin
how does the white house
see this visit and the timing of this
visit
and do you guys expect anything from the
brazilian president during this meeting
if you simply looked at a catalog of the
engagements the president has had with
his allies and partners including the
engagement he had today
that catalog alone would be a rebuttal
to the proposition that he's not doing
enough to rally the west and to offer
russia
a credible diplomatic path out of this
uh that's included phone calls it's
included meetings it's included video
conferences uh it's included
countless sustained effort over the
course of months
and we will continue with that and we're
also very proud to have the vice
president representing the american
delegation at the munich security
conference
meeting vladimir putin next week
the brazilian president is obviously you
know free to
conduct his own diplomacy with other
countries including with russia and i i
really don't have anything else to add
on it today
yes uh thanks jake you mentioned the
possibility of an assault on kiev
specifically what is your sense if putin
does decide to invade ukraine is he
looking to invade and take over the
entire country or a part like crimea in
2014. and just one follow-up as well
how do you explain the disconnects
between the rhetoric that we're hearing
or the warnings we're hearing from you
and other western countries and what
seems to be a playing down
of the risk from ukraine itself
so i won't speak to the the decisions
that the ukrainian leadership is making
in terms of how they're communicating on
this issue i will only say that we are
coordinating extremely closely with them
president biden has spoken multiple
times with president zielenski i speak
nearly every day
with senior aides to president zielenski
secretary blinken is deeply engaged with
both his counterpart and the president
and kiev so we will continue that level
of coordination sharing of information
across every dimension of our government
but i can't characterize why it is that
they're choosing their course i can only
say that based on the information we
have we've chosen uh to be
as transparent as possible with what we
see as a significant risk of military
action
in ukraine
and as to your other question i can't
obviously predict what the exact shape
or scope of the military action will be
as i said before it could take a variety
of forms
it could be more limited it could be
more expansive
but there are very real possibilities
that it will involve the seizure of a
significant amount of territory in
ukraine and the seizure of major cities
including the capital city
the president's departure is at 225 and
so if people want to leave they need to
leave now if people want to leave they
should leave now we'll proceed yeah
you should depart now
do you think that
do you think that russia thank you sorry
i'm just going to give people a moment
to i guess if they have to
okay yeah thank you jake
i'll wait until people get up
[Music]
okay you for taking my question
did the us wait too long to arm ukraine
especially with respect to weapons that
could defend against an airstrike like
you laid out did they wait too long to
move
u.s forces to nato countries
and does the president still view the
idea of pre-invasion sanctions as a
stupid question
so uh as to the question of waiting too
long on arming the ukrainians
over the course of the past year the
united states has provided more than
half a billion dollars 650 million
dollars in defensive assistance to
ukraine that's more than has ever been
given by any president in any year at
any time and that began
more than a year ago under the
presidency of joe biden second we have
made good on the commitment to get those
deliveries into the hands of the
ukrainian armed forces those are
defensive weapons
intended to defend ukraine against
aggression they are not meant for
offensive purposes against any country
so we feel uh very proud of the
contribution and commitment that we have
had to helping the ukrainians be able to
defend themselves with respect to the
question of the deployment of forces to
defend nato territory our view is that
in addition to the 80 000 strong u.s
force presence in europe today
that's showing in poland and romania in
particular but also through the
deployment of air squadrons to the
baltics as we had a few days ago and
other significant moves we've made a
carrier uh in the mediterranean that for
the first time in 30 years actually flew
the nato flag as well as the american
flag
that we have been forward-leaning and
robust in defending and reassuring our
nato allies and you don't have to take
it from me you can talk to the president
of poland or the president of romania
about the satisfaction they have with
the fact that the united states has
stepped up alongside other nato allies
uh to deter and reassure uh and
reinforce uh our presence along the
eastern flank
what about the pre-invasion sanctions
you didn't answer that part of my
question is the president looking at
sanctions ahead of an invasion any
differently than he has been up until
this point given the escalation that
we're seeing from russia the president
believes that sanctions are intended to
deter
and in order for them to work to deter
they have to be set up in a way where if
putin moves
then the costs are imposed we believe
that that is the right logic
both on its own merits but equally
importantly we believe that the most
important
fundamental
for anything that unfolds in this crisis
whether through diplomacy or as a result
of military action is that the west be
strong be united and be determined to
operate with common purpose and he
believes that the sanctions approach
he's taken in lockstep with our european
partners the canadians and others puts
us in a position for the west to be able
to respond to this contingency in the
most united and purposeful way possible
that will pay dividends for us in this
circumstance but it will also pay
enormous strategic dividends for the
united states in the years and decades
our understanding is that there was a
sudden meeting last night in the
situation room to talk about russia and
now you and secretary blanken are
obviously using sharper
rhetoric about the timing of the
invasion i know you don't want to get
into specific intelligence but is there
something that prompted the meeting last
night
and that has changed the
administration's assessment overnight so
i'm not going to speak to internal
deliberations and i'm not going to get
into the specifics of intelligence
information what i am going to say
is that for some time now
including out of my own very mouth we
have been talking about how we had
entered the window where any day now
a military action could be taken that
was the formula i was using several days
ago now
as we gain more information
our view
that military action could occur any day
now and could occur before the end of
the olympics
is
only growing in terms of its robustness
so that i can stand here and say that is
a very very distinct possibility but i
just want to say two things first we
can't predict
uh the exact
determination that putin would make if
and when he makes a determination so all
we can say
is
that the the the strong possibility of
action the distinct possibility of
action in a relatively near-term time
frame um including along the time frame
that i've laid out that secretary
blinken talked about that is backed up
by our view of what's happening on the
ground and it's backed up by information
that we continue to acquire day by day
including over the course of the past
few days
why
why would russia risk provoking china uh
with an action during the olympics and
secondly can you just speak more broadly
to the china
russia
what looks like an emerging alliance
here on certain issues and how much does
that concern you
so i'd say
three things about this first
you know russia's calculus vis-a-vis
china whether they're going to make
beijing upset or not you know that's
kind of between russia and china and
putin will obviously have to decide what
he wants to do on that front china also
has its own decisions to make and to the
extent that they are giving a wink and a
nod or a green light to a russian
invasion of ukraine
for no
justified reason i believe that china
will ultimately come to suffer
consequences as a result of that in the
eyes of the rest of the world most
notably in the eyes of our european
partners and allies and then finally i
would just say that we do not believe
that china can compensate russia for the
economic losses that would be sustained
in the event of an invasion uh due to
sanctions and export controls and the
like
just one more thing on the broader issue
of china and russia because there was
quite a bit of hype about the statement
that they put out and it was a notable
statement that we have taken careful
uh a careful look at
uh i've said this before i want to say
it again and then i'll leave because jen
is now standing up and i think it's well
past my time to go the united states
under the biden administration has
confidence
in
us and in the west we are 50
plus of global gdp china and russia are
less than 20 percent we have innovation
we have entrepreneurship we have freedom
and when you put all of that together
the the tools and capacities that we can
bring to bear now that we are more
united more purposeful more dynamic than
we have been in a very long time
we are well situated to be able to deal
with any threat or challenge that would
be posed to us by any autocracy in the
world including the two that you just
mentioned so let me just leave
thank you
sanctions right guys
to be clear you can come as long as you
want
i just don't want to get in trouble with
your team when we ask you to come back
the next time uh
abs absolutely apologize for the
confusion so he's the president's still
in a meeting corrine here is going to
monitor when he gets out of the meeting
when you all need to depart armor or
others if you want to come back sorry we
did not want you to miss the president's
departure but we had a little
miscommunication internally
yes and he is he is still meeting so it
will not leave without him we have been
assured of that um
okay um i don't have anything at the top
i know you've covered a lot of topics
but i know there's a lot going on in the
world so why don't we go to whatever
else or that that you'd like to discuss
what should we expect this weekend
things have obviously
um escalated or moved forward who is the
president going to be talking to
european leaders
what should we expect this weekend just
moves forward sure well as you know the
president just spoke with a number of
his european counterparts as well as uh
prime minister trudeau i believe we put
out did we put out to have you seen a
readout yet of our of his call with
prime minister trudeau if not i will
give it to you right now have you seen
it yet in your inbox
okay this is what happens when you don't
bring your phone out here so uh here you
go um today uh but prime minister
trudeau was obviously part of the
planned meeting as well he also had a
separate meeting with him where he uh
they discussed the ongoing blockade of
key bridges and crossings between the
united states and canada including
detroit windsor sweetwater
coots and pambina emerson the two
leaders agree that the actions of the
individuals who are obstructing travel
and commerce between our two countries
are having significant direct impacts on
citizens lives and livelihoods the
president expressed his concern that the
united states that united states
companies and workers are experiencing
serious effects including slowdowns in
production shortened work hours and
plant closures the prime minister
promised quick action in enforcing the
law and the president thanked him for
the steps he and other canadian
authorities are taking to restore the
open passage of bridges to the united
states in turn the prime minister also
thanked the president and his
administration the governor of michigan
and u.s officials for all of the
assistance that we have provided to
resolve the disruption and the two
leaders agreed to stay in close touch in
terms of this weekend i just wanted you
to have that component another important
thing happening right now uh in terms of
this weekend as you know the president
will be in camp at camp david uh which
is fully equipped to have engagements of
all sorts including with his including
with his national security team or
european counterparts we are making
these decisions about who he'll engage
with on a day-by-day basis we will keep
you all abreast of that as we have done
to date but he is he'll be at camp david
and i would expect that he'll be engaged
closely with his teams here as well as
uh his foreign counterparts uh on a
supreme court
when will president meet with the senate
republicans uh in the judiciary
committee and also just a point of
clarification from the interview with uh
lester holt
uh about i believe he said about four
people who's doing the deep dive
uh three and a half four and a half uh
there's no three and a half people homer
if you could just offer
are we down to
four uh finalists well i'm not going to
build on what the president said it is
natural that as this process has
proceeded that the list would be
come smaller that's a natural part of
the process but
again as he's said many times he is
looking at a range of qualified
individuals strong legal minds
individuals with strong credentials who
have strong character and a dedication
to the rule of law but in terms of the
specific numbers i understand your
question it's natural to be
growing smaller but i don't have any
anything to build on to what he said
senate republicans
he will continue to
consult closely with democrats and
republicans that will continue into next
week but i don't have a anything to
preview for you at this point in time go
ahead thanks jen uh the diplomats that
are being moved out of the u.s embassy
in ukraine where are they going are they
going to
other countries are they being taken to
safer locations within
ukraine what can you tell us it's a it's
a great question i'd really refer you to
the state department typically when we
reduce a presence at an embassy that
means they depart the country uh but i
can certainly check with them and get
you more details on that typically it
means they would return to a home base
what's the administration's current
assessment of putin's strategy in the
black sea is it to cut off ukraine's
naval access
in terms of the exercises i mean our
assessment is that this is a part of
ongoing escalatory actions whether it's
military exercises or the buildup of
more troops
that we have seen at the border in terms
of what it means and what he's preparing
for i would point you to what our
national security advisor just said
which is that you know we continue to
watch closely to assess our role here is
to prepare for a range of
a range of steps he might take but
beyond that i don't have any prediction
of what that means
thanks jen has the u.s shared the latest
intelligence with ukraine and
do does the us feel that ukrainian
government is properly
preparing its citizens for the
possibility of a war because it seems
like they keep down playing it
well i'm not going to speak for how the
ukrainian officials leaders speak or
engage with their citizens but we do
engage very closely with them sharing of
information as we do with our european
counterparts and that has been the case
at every point in this process
is the state department doing anything
right now to help americans get out of
ukraine or just warning them to get out
on their own
well we have been warning for several
weeks now if not longer that american
citizens should depart and i think you
heard our national security adviser give
a pretty stark warning of what would
happen on purpose uh what would happen
uh if russia were to invade uh in
the difficulty of uh not just
being in the middle of a military
zone but also the difficulty of
departing or getting out and the fact
that departure
means of departure could be cut off and
that was we feel important for american
citizens in ukraine to understand
we have been conveying that if american
citizens don't have the means to depart
that we would provide assistance uh for
those purposes that has been the case
for several weeks now if we don't know
if putin has made up his mind why are we
hearing this warning from jake sullivan
that americans should get out ideally
within the next 24 to 48 hours
specifically i don't believe we've heard
that window from him before uh because i
we recognize that if president putin
were to decide to invade that this would
make it a a very difficult
circumstance on the ground for american
citizens we don't have an assessment as
he as you heard him say of him making
that decision but he could make that
decision at any point and we want to be
very clear and direct with american
citizens about the risk that uh that
would pose to them
that the risk the risk that would be
posed to any civilian if they remain uh
in the country this is now the second
evacuation of americans
um
not actually an evacuation to be clear
american citizens can depart ukraine
there are means of departing uh ukraine
this is not a country where we are at
war where we have tens of thousands of
troops who have been fighting a war for
20 years so it's incredibly different
correct you are correct in that but
we're it's the second time we've urged
american citizens
to get out of a country actually we've
urged american citizens to depart a
number of times uh and that is
well i think this but let me finish here
because i think it's important for
people to understand we urged american
citizens to depart kazakhstan we urged
american citizens to depart ethiopia
this is a responsibility that the state
department and our diplomat diplomats
who are serving there and serving around
the world take on to keep american
citizens safe and it it may not be front
and center on the news in the united
states but those are conflict areas and
zones where we are constantly monitoring
these are the two major events that have
happened under this administration and
what does
i would say the people in ethiopia would
differ with that as with the people in
kazakhstan or other parts of the world
where uh there has been they have been
under dangerous uh circumstances and
they look to the united states to
provide up-to-date information of their
safety and security in the country
president has frequently
talked about getting out of afghanistan
as a major event it has impacted his
polling this is a current event that is
underway the question is what does the
administration say to critics who are
looking at these two events
and questioning this administration's
foreign policy approach who is
questioning us plenty of republicans
like who
i could name off any number of
republicans
i'd love to know a name goodness
mitch mcconnell
okay well here's what i would say to mr
mcconnell uh the president ended a
20-year war in afghanistan
a war that had cost us thousands of
american lives
billions trillions of dollars and was a
failed enterprise after 20 years he was
the first president to do that after
many of his predecessors failed to take
exactly that step
we knew it would be complicated we knew
it'd be challenging he had the courage
to get our troops out of there and end a
20-year war this is entirely different
because we are not ending a 20-year war
we are trying to prevent war here we are
trying to keep american citizens safe uh
in ukraine by encouraging them to depart
by providing them information about what
the security circumstances are on the
ground and i think it's important for
the american public to understand these
significant differences between these
different scenarios go ahead
back to the supreme court for a moment
can you
rule out that the president would be
meeting with any of his
candidates this weekend at
camp david
here's what i can tell you i i there's
not plans for that but i can tell you
that uh it could be as early as next
week i would not echo uh reporting that
it is definitely next week
given the
heightened a state of concern about
russia and ukraine does that at all
affect the timetable for the president
on his supreme court pick simply because
of the time and attention he would need
to devote to that and because senate
democrats were very
upfront saying they're encouraging the
president to move quickly do you sense
that there is an increase in the tempo
for the president to move on his
selection process
we remain on track for the president to
make a decision an announcement on who
he's going to dominate to the supreme
court this month in the next few weeks
that was his intention from the
beginning remains his intention now and
he will continue to
read a range of cases study uh the
materials about a range of candidates
that has not been changed by uh
whatever decision president putin makes
go ahead
in the nbc interview the president said
he rejected the findings of the
after-action report about the state
department and military response to
afghanistan does that mean the president
has ruled out any
action that might be viewed or read as
accountability well steve i think it's
important for people to understand there
was there was no after action report the
washington post report was not an after
action report
it was based on a range of foia
documents which is their right to do
based on individual interviews of
members of the military including many
who were not a part of policy making
decisions in the situation room some
were many were not but that is not an
after-action report
there was also a report from centcom on
the attack at abby gate on friday which
the president certainly stands by and
that was important work vital work a
formal report and review that was done
internally so i just want to separate
the two for people's understanding
what the president was rejecting
is the notion that there weren't a range
of preparations done
in advance
over the course of last spring and last
summer and it's important to remember
that we made the decision he made the
decision to end a 20-year war
he came into office without any plan
well there was a there was a deadline
but without any plan for departure or
for helping the the uh the afghans who
had served by our side for 20 years we
put in place and this is in this is in
these same documents
beginning last spring a plan a range of
contingency plans should we need to
bring american citizens out or bring
afghans out we put in a place we
positioned military troops on the ground
working with department of defense back
in early summer to ensure that we could
execute on that plan and in every single
meeting last august the president asked
the team and often ended the meeting
with this
is there anything you need to implement
what your plans are is there anything
you need on the ground he always
ended with that i'd also note that he
always raised uh the question of whether
we needed to evacuate our embassy
and people are americans who were
serving in our embassy there that
decision was always posed to the group
at the table that decision was not made
until august 12th so reporting that
suggests otherwise is incorrect uh that
is this that is the state of play that
happened last summer go ahead a question
on inflation since this is the first
time we've heard everything since those
numbers came out um the president has
said the administration is going to
continue to be all hands on deck to try
and bring prices back down uh can you
guess a sense of what that really looks
like because you know you pointed many
times to parts of the buildback better
again that that remains stalled in fact
one of senator manchin's big objections
uh to the bill was the high rate of
inflation so if the buildback better
plan sort of remains at this impasse
what's plan b to try and bring down some
police costs well there's a couple steps
that the president is very focused on as
it relates to addressing inflation one i
would note that economists in the
federal reserve still predict that
inflation will come down will moderate
over the course of the year and the
president has also said that he supports
the steps that the federal reserve an
independent body has announced about
recalibrating over the course of the
coming months and he's obviously
nominated a number of individuals to
fill the board which is an essential
part of addressing this
but i would also know beyond that how
the president really looks at this is
how you're addressing core costs for the
american people so you reference the
build back better plan first we believe
there's a path forward and the
president's going to continue to fight
for it otherwise he wouldn't have gone
to virginia earlier this week and talked
about negotiating the price of
prescription drugs so his view is that
in order to address
costs that have been affecting inflation
but also infecting families for many
decades the cost of prescription drugs
the cost of child care we need to move
that forward but it's not just that we
also need to address supply chains in
the short term at the ports rebuild our
manufacturing infrastructure
make sure that we are implementing the
bipartisan partisan infrastructure
law and continuing to press for the
competitiveness legislation that will
help ensure we have funding for chips
for manufacturing of cars here in the
united states and you've also heard him
talk a fair amount about promoting
competition and that addresses issues
like we've seen price increases in the
meat industry and others and that will
help bring down costs for americans so
there is certainly a significant and
important a his vital role that the
federal reserve plays they are
independent he wants that board to be
completely filled but there are a number
of uh other steps we are working to take
to lower costs for the american people
just one follow-up on the question about
the embassy
you've said that you're continuing to
reduce the size of the embassy to be
clear you're not talking about closing
the embassy just yet so what
size are we talking about how much of a
reduction here i would really i can
check with the state department it's a
good question but they really have
purview over those numbers and that's uh
that's where we are at the in the
process at this point in time go ahead
jen what does the white house make of
the reporting that former president
trump is uh still in touch with kim
jong-un
uh well former president trump is not
the president um and we
president biden is the president and he
is the one who conducts diplomacy on
behalf of the united states
one other topic i see that the president
spoke with the prime minister trudeau
about
the blockade
what is um is the white house doing
to help sort of
alleviate that the trade issues that he
raised in that call
and
more broadly it is the white house or is
the government preparing for any kind of
similar um types of of demonstrations
here
yeah so two different questions so let
me try to answer them both so uh we have
continued obviously the president's
speaking with prime minister trudeau
about this as part of our effort but our
team uh list sure what dr lisher would
randall other members of our
administration have been in close touch
with their canadian counterpart parts
over the last few days about how to
address this blockade and the challenge
it is posing to the supply chain i mean
fundamentally how we view this is that
the impact of these protests while we
certainly believe in peaceful protest
is impacting has the potential to impact
and this is why we are very focused on
this communities workers being able to
travel back and forth across the bridge
who are going to work who may work on
different sides of the border the
ability to get food on the table to
american families to get auto parts to
manufacturers who are trying to make
vehicles so this is whatever their
intended stated purpose is this
effort is is going to have has the
potential to have a huge impact on
workers and the american public but to
go back to your question we are in very
close contact with canadian officials
we've also taken steps to help
detour
routes so that a number of these trucks
can move in different routes and be able
to cross the border so for example
while the windsor detroit ambassador
bridge continues to remain closed port
huron is fully operational customs and
border patrol is rerouting traffic to
port huron where all nine commercial
lanes are open the detroit windsor
tunnel is open which is a way that
individuals who are trying to work on
different sides of the border are able
to travel as well and secretary mayorkas
has also spoken with local officials in
affected and potentially affected states
as has secretary buda judge has been
deeply involved with this as well on
your second question um you know we are
um
of course on reports of a similar
freedom convoy i think you're asking
about right in dc event in dc in early
march the department of homeland
security obviously put out a statement
on this the other night they're aware of
these reports they're taking all
necessary steps to ensure that the
convoy does not disrupt lawful trade and
transportation or interfere with federal
government and law enforcement
operations on reports that this convoy
is causing disruptions at the super bowl
the department of homeland security or
could i should say the department of
homeland security is surging additional
staff
to its incident command post their
strong cooperation with the california
highway patrol the los angeles police
department and state and local
authorities and the department already
has a lead field coordinator and
emergency operations center in place as
would be standard protocol given this is
a large event the super bowl and
they will build on that there's already
uh 500 dhs personnel providing extensive
air and maritime security resources so
we are in both close touch with our
canadian counterparts also with local
officials through our department of
homeland security uh our secretary of
transportation is also deeply involved
in this and we're working to address
this on all fronts
thanks jen just to follow up on jeff's
question is it still accurate to say
that the bind administration has not
heard back from the north koreans
despite the outreach correct
and on the conversation that president
biden is expected to have with president
putin is that happening today
i don't have anything to predict in
terms of the timing okay and i think we
have to wrap it up um you want to do the
last one quick real quick uh well can i
ask on two things yeah well first of all
following up on
what you said earlier confirming that
interviews with supreme court candidates
could begin as early as next week does
he have to find
how many he wants to interview is it
just a
few you know is there a number that he
has in mind and how long do you expect
that process the interview meeting
process to go just next week or further
well what i can tell you is that the
interview process for any president
typically happens very late in the
process
and
in terms of the specific number i'm just
not going to get into that level of
detail
uh i'm asking for a colleague regarding
his position on the bankruptcy law for
student loan debt president biden voted
repeatedly as a senator to make it
harder for student loan borrowers to
erase their debts through baker's
bankruptcy like other secured debts such
as credit cards two years ago as a
presidential campaign he campaigned on
overhauling the bankruptcy law to e
student debt in addition to his pledge
to forgive ten thousand dollars per
student in federal uh student loans why
hasn't he acted to this point on uh the
bankruptcy law in addition to
the pledge on
debt forgiveness i'm happy to check on
the status of that legislation i don't
know where it is in the process but what
i could reiterate for you is that the
president has forgiven 15 billion
dollars in student loans benefiting more
than 675 000 student loan borrowers
since he took office no one has been
required to pay a single dime in federal
student loans and he extended uh the the
um
the hiatus of payment until may to give
people some extra breathing room i'll
check and see the stats event
application advisor pulling the
application for the authorization for
the vaccines for under five is there a
white house reaction to that i i know
they're going to do a briefing the fda
is so i will leave it to them to speak
to their data thanks everyone about the
cia's master of airlines
you